vamos a resolver otro ejemplo con el
teorema de green supongamos que tenemos
una trayectoria en el plano x que que
recorre el círculo unitario voy a poner
aquí el eje y voy a poner aquí
perpendicularmente el eje x y entonces
la trayectoria recorre la orilla del
círculo que tiene centro en el origen y
radio 1 entonces se ve más o menos así
vamos a recorrer este círculo en el
sentido horario es decir en el sentido
de las manecillas del reloj a ver
espérame tantito aquí apareció algo así
en el sentido de las manecillas del
reloj o sea nos quedaría con las flechas
en este sentido aquí al lado voy a poner
la ecuación de este círculo es x
cuadrada más y cuadrada igual a 1 el 1
nos dice que el círculo tiene radio lo
que nos interesa es calcular una
integral de línea de lo siguiente
encontrar la integral de línea en esta
curva se en el sentido bueno voy a
dibujar al revés en el sentido
en el sentido horario en el sentido de
las manecillas del reloj v2 de x menos
- 3x de ella va entonces para como vamos
seguro estamos ansiosos de usar el
teorema de green y porque no a ver
recordemos que nos dice el teorema de
green dice que la integral de curva
de una curva cerrada de f punto de r
donde a ver dónde f es igual a a ver
déjame ponerle un poco más claro fx y
donde fx
pd x
por y más q de equis
j entonces lo que dice es que la
integral de aquí es igual a una doble
integral a la doble integral sobre la
región r esta de aquí es la región r
de qué cosa pues de una de una cierta
función que está dada por las parciales
la primera es la parcial de q con
respecto a x la parcial de q con
respecto a x y luego hay que restar
menos la parcial de p con respecto a g
y todo eso de a
recordemos que esta idea representa las
pequeñas áreas en que dividimos la
región ahora a lo mejor te acuerdes o no
pero voy a repetir lo que dije al
comienzo del vídeo anterior hay un
detallito que tenemos que verificar que
tiene que ver con el sentido de la curva
el teorema de greene funciona cuando
recorremos la curva en sentido
antihorario sin embargo en este ejemplo
aquí tenemos lo contrario estamos
recorriendo el círculo en sentido
horario en el sentido de las manecillas
del reloj así esta ecuación que es la de
green aplica cuando la región queda a la
izquierda y en este caso hay que
recorrer la curva en el sentido
antihorario pero nosotros no tenemos
este caso nosotros tenemos el otro
verdad en nuestro ejemplo la región nos
queda del lado derecho y entonces el
teorema de green necesita un signo menos
entonces vamos a escribir aquí abajo la
integral sobre la curva c la integral
cerrada en sentido horario de f punto de
r va a ser igual a la doble integral
sobre la región r pero vamos a
intercambiar estos dos
con respecto al menos la parcial de q
con respecto a x
metamos las funciones esto de aquí nos
queda la doble integral
sobre la región r
ok y tenemos que derivar vámonos a ver
dónde está el campo vectorial a ver
nuestro campo vectorial viene de viene
de acá arriba verdad esto de aquí es
nuestra nuestra p esa de allí es la px y
entonces vamos a vamos a ponerle nombre
a estos dos componentes de acá al de la
izquierda que tiene que ver con dx es px
y al segundo que tiene que ver con de y
le vamos a poner de equis y ya lo dije
muchas veces pero una vez más esto
aparece porque hacemos un producto punto
con de r
entonces el p aparece con el de x pero
no con el de por qué se cancelan con
productos punto y otras cosas que ya
vimos en los otros vídeos bueno no nos
vamos a meter a esos detalles ahorita si
quieres puedes repasar los en el vídeo
anterior pero cuál es la parcial de p
con respecto a y aps está muy fácil
verdad es 2 la derivada de 2 y con
respecto ayer 2 y luego hay que restar
la derivada de menos 3x con respecto a x
también está muy fácil es menos 3 nos
queda menos 3
todo eso de a y eso de ahí es igual a la
doble integral sobre la región rd2 menos
-3 podemos ponerle más a los dos porque
menos por menos da más nos queda 5 vea
esto de aquí es una constante podemos
sacarla de la integral lo voy a hacer
por aquí abajito vas a ver que nos va a
quedar algo muy sencillo nos queda cinco
veces la integral doble sobre el bea
ahora qué es esta doble integral qué
sentido geométrico le podemos dar a esta
doble integral que no tiene nada adentro
pues eso simplemente es el área de la
región r
esta doble integral representa eso
porque simplemente estamos sumando todos
estos de a en toda la región de entonces
sumamos todas esas áreas multiplicadas
por 1 eso simplemente nos da el área eso
está muy padre bueno vamos a recordar
nuestras fórmulas de círculos de
primaria nuestra fórmula de círculo de
primaria nos dice que el área es igual a
ti por radio al cuadrado y cuál es el
radio pues ya dijimos como ese círculo
unitario tiene radio igual a 1 entonces
está muy fácil el área es pi entonces
esta expresión esta doble integral
simplemente es igual a ti bueno entonces
la respuesta de nuestra integral es 5 y
eso estuvo muy fácil pudimos haber hecho
el proceso como antes pudimos haber
encontrado la anti derivada definir
algunos límites y no se hubiera quedado
lo mismo pero es era pues un poco
espantoso verdad pero bueno porque no
pensamos en algo todavía más espantoso
ay te vale te voy a hacer un reto el
reto consiste en lo siguiente te reto a
que todo este problema lo empieces desde
la definición de integral de línea
toma esta expresión de aquí plantea una
parametrización de la curva es decir da
un valor de t que recorre en esa
dirección encuentras las parciales luego
encuentra la anti derivada y evalúa vas
a ver que eso va a ser mucho más
espantoso de lo que estábamos haciendo
ahorita entonces el teorema de greene
nos simplificó muchísimo este problema
recuerda que tuvimos que poner un más
bien un menos y por lo del sentido de la
curva si hubiéramos ido hacia el otro
lado hubiéramos obtenido un menos sale
espero que este vídeo te haya sido de
mucha ayuda hasta la próxima